of course the show does end on a
cliffhanger unlike my novel not every
thread has been tied up nor every
question answers
still looking
[Music]
for Laurel Gates and Tyler just Pawns in
a bigger game
well today's stalker become tomorrow's
nemesis
what do you hope to explore in a
possible second season honestly I don't
know I guess peel back more layers maybe
learn more about Wednesday I do I kind
of want her to be darker okay I want her
to get more in the nitty-gritty of
things and not play things so safe
because there's a lot of lines this one
about her ah it's just saving the school
and doing whatever but for me her main
drive with the monster was kind of a
competitiveness kind of man how's this
guy doing this and why can't I so I
think I think I wanted to I want to
continue down an anti-hero stream rather
than typical hero if you know what I
mean good evening girls I'm Miss
Thornhill I trust Enid has given you the
old Nevermore welcome Christina ricci's
character takes twists that I did not
see come in
please don't make this more difficult
than what already is Marilyn
[Applause]
what was your reaction to the ending and
knowing the fate of Christina's
character I kind of anticipated it you
did yeah so I wasn't too
I wasn't too worried about it I thought
I was just excited to see what what she
would do you know because it's one thing
to read something on a page but I've
never done something so fantasy oriented
either so I was just kind of wondering
oh I wonder what this is going to look
like yeah how bees come in you know it
was I thought it was a brilliant choice
because you know you don't anticipate
that coming yeah I know you did but
you're smarter than me well I remember
on the day Christina was saying I have a
gun in my hand and you're gonna tell me
that a bee lands on it and I decide not
to shoot like there was there's a lot of
logical thing totally that you question
but then again with a show like this
it's it's camping fun and it's not
supposed to be taken seriously yeah I
think sometimes you just have to shut
logical thoughts down and just kind of
let the fantasy play out especially when
it Burton if it's Tim Burton you kind of
have to just suspend your disbelief and
just like let them go yeah yeah I think
his approve on everything or his his
overseeing everything was comforting
[Music]